here's a graph showing the population
growth in four US cities from 1860 to
1900 in 1860 before the Civil War New
York City was the biggest city in the
United States but even it didn't have
more than a million people there wasn't
a single city of more than a million in
the whole country at that point compare
that to just 40 years later when not one
but three cities had passed the million
mark and New York had nearly 3.5 million
residents proportionally Chicago's
population growth was even more drastic
from only about 100,000 residents in
1860 it got 17 times bigger by 1900 with
about 1.7 million residents
traditionally Americans had been a
pretty rural farming people but starting
in the late 19th century there was a
rapid shift towards urbanization by 1920
urban residents would outnumber country
dwellers in the United States for the
first time and today more than 80
percent of Americans live in cities so
what led to this explosion in the
population of cities in the decades
after the Civil War the major factors
behind this shift were industrialization
immigration and migration now we've been
talking about those three things in
various forums in American history up
until this point from the cool
inventions of the first Industrial
Revolution to the influx of Irish and
German immigrants in the 1840s to the
movement of Americans ever westward so
industrialization immigration and
migration weren't new forces in American
society but there were unique aspects of
all three of these processes during the
Gilded Age that contributed to the
development of cities in this era one
thing that changed was the nature of
work that people did during the Gilded
Age there was a tipping point in the
American labor market in 1880 for the
first time ever the number of people who
worked for someone else for wages people
who had a boss and needed to do what
they said to get paid outnumbered
Americans who worked for themselves like
farmers who could decide for themselves
when to sow or harvest their crops the
second
real revolution which began after the
Civil War was a booming era of expansion
and industrial production so there were
a lot of factory jobs available and most
of those jobs were for unskilled
laborers that is workers who don't
require any kind of special training
before they start a job so there was an
overall transition from farm work that
was self directed to unskilled factory
work done for a boss another change
during the Gilded Age was in who was
doing the immigrating and migrating
until the 1840s most immigrants to the
United States had been Protestant
Christians from northern and western
Europe and they were relatively well-off
financially after the Civil War a
variety of factors abroad combined with
the wide availability of jobs in the
United States brought different types of
immigrants to American cities these new
immigrants as they were called tended to
be from Southern and Eastern Europe
Mexico and Asia and they differed from
old immigrants in that they tended to be
poorer have darker complexions and
practice Catholicism or Judaism instead
of Protestantism in addition in this era
African Americans from the south began
to migrate to northern and Midwestern
cities all of these immigrants and
migrants created a large industrial
workforce but why did they all move to
the city let's take a look at some of
the push and pull factors that prompted
people to uproot themselves and head to
American cities during the Gilded Age
first there were push factors or things
that were pushing people out of their
previous living situations a big one was
poverty and just a lack of financial
mobility at home farmers in many
countries were hit hard by the
mechanization of Agriculture which
happened in this time period about a
third of the people moving to cities
were Americans leaving farms and heading
to the city for industrial jobs
another push factor was persecution and
discrimination at home the Russian
government took in
creasing lis intolerant position towards
Jews in this time period who were
subject to mob violence and campaigns of
ethnic cleansing in Europe in the
American South the emergence of Jim Crow
laws and an increase in lynchings were
among the reasons that African Americans
elected to leave after the Civil War but
what were the poll factors that landed
them in cities for one thing many
struggling immigrants from abroad didn't
have the money to go anywhere else so
after they arrived they just stayed put
but the main reason that people moved to
cities is because that's where the jobs
were with the development of steam power
and electrification factories no longer
had to be located next to waterways so
cities developed as industrial hubs
often cities would develop as the center
for one specific industry like steel in
Pittsburgh meatpacking in Chicago or
clothing in New York people also found
communities of support in cities earlier
immigrants might send money and
information to their families and
friends back home helping them to move
and get established this facilitated the
development of urban neighborhoods where
people from similar backgrounds spoke
the same language ate the same food and
provided each other with assistance in
these ethnic enclaves people could get
newspapers and even go to see theater
performances in their native languages
so let's finish by taking a look at two
narratives of immigrants arriving in
American cities in this time period the
first one is from Lee Chu who immigrated
to San Francisco from China at age 16 in
the year 1880 he wrote when I got to San
Francisco which was before the passage
of the exclusion act I was half starved
because I was afraid to eat the
provisions of the barbarians but a few
days living in the Chinese quarter made
me happy again a man got me work as a
house servant in an American family when
I went to work for that American family
I could not speak a word of English and
I didn't know anything about housework I
did not understand what the lady said to
me but she showed me how to cook wash
iron sweep dust make beds wash dishes
clean windows paint and brass polished
the knives and forks etc in six months I
had learned how to do the work of our
house quite
well and I was getting $5 a weekend
board and putting away about 425 a week
I'd also learned some English I sent
money home to comfort my parents but
though I dressed well and lived well and
had pleasure going quite often to the
Chinese Theatre and to dinner parties in
Chinatown
I saved $50 in the first six months the
second one is from Mary Anton who
immigrated to Boston from what is now
Belarus at the age of 13 in the year
1894 she wrote the first meal was an
object lesson of much variety
my father produced several kinds of food
ready to eat without any cooking from
little tin cans that had printing all
over them he attempted to introduce us
to a queer slippery kind of fruit which
he called banana but had to give it up
for the time being on our second day a
little girl from across the alley came
and offered to conduct us to school my
father was out but we five between us
had a few words of English by this time
we knew the word school we understood
this child who had never seen us till
yesterday who could not pronounce our
names who was not much better dressed
than we was able to offer us the freedom
of the schools of Boston we had to visit
the stores and be dressed from head to
foot in American clothing we had to
learn the mysteries of the iron stove
the washboard and the speaking-tube and
above all we had to learn English with
our despised immigrant clothing we shed
also our impossible Hebrew names a
committee of our friends several years
ahead of us an American experience put
their heads together and concocted
American names for us all so what
similarities and differences do you see
between the experiences of Lee Chiu and
Mary Anton why do you think they
emigrated to American cities and what do
you think their lives would be like
going forward in the Gilded Age